my big thing is someone else's victories
are not my losses like this scarcity
mindset thing is fascinating in sports
you play a game someone wins someone
lose that's why I love it it's so
absolute but in life like not games
7,000 DJs could be winning plus every
DJ's winning is different attention is
the number one
asset podcast with friends is live
episode two of the show I'm excited
about this one because I think for the
audience that's listening you're about
to meet three new friends some of you
may know some of them some of you may
know all three which I would love first
big shout out to Twitch again if you're
listening to this podcast we are now
also doing this live on Twitch all the
time and so I'd need to give a quick
couple of shout outs oh bird UK is on
which is always nice big vriend
Community member T Walsh giving Boyd
love you know T Walsh if you have any
problems working for Boyd put it out
here in the twitch uh comments I'm going
to allow all three of our friends uh to
introduce themselves and then we're just
going to talk about a bunch of stuff but
one thing I do need is boy uh Boyd go
out there and tell them I need some be
friends packs for our friends and some
of the swag on the table Dustin I
thought you guys were going to have
like changing it up no no no anyway
let's do this why don't you say hello to
everybody tell everybody who you are and
what you do hi everyone I'm Ashlyn
Harris I'm a newly retired professional
Prof athlete uh spent all my Years
playing soccer yes quite successfully I
you're going to be humble now please
please give a little bit more juice for
the people that don't know because it's
not that simple you truly are one of the
like it's one thing to be like we're
tired a it's another thing to be like
actually one of the best at what you did
kind of thing so go a little bit like
we're I'm giving you the permission to
be a hairless humble because really one
of thing just to let you know and more
importantly the AUD or equally
importantly the audience cuz this is new
for me I've always loved the idea of
getting different people together from
different genres like in real life like
this is how I like to have dinner
totally you know like one
conversation and I just think this is a
fun podcast strategy for me because for
example us like like I want more I'm so
stretched so like this allows me to like
spend more time with more people and
more importantly I want my audience to
be a renaissance man and woman meaning I
think one of the things that's lacking
is curiosity and expansion you know and
I think like what I'm excited about is I
know over the course of the next five
years that this podcast will be listened
to millions of times obviously a lot
upfront and then long tail yeah and uh I
want people to know who you you guys are
you're a sweetheart so please go ah hair
a little less hi I'm Ashlin Harris
retired professional soccer player
two-time Women's World Cup
champion uh one of the plaintiffs who
fought for equal pay in women's soccer
and kind of spiraled worldwide so uh
yeah that's kind of my that's a better
St was that better thanks for giving me
I needed that Li Clark um my name is
Will Clark I from the UK DJ producer
podcaster much it and Andy late edition
we had somebody who got sick and I was
like you know what this is fun like even
when something gets thrown as a
curveball I've always got real friends
in the office doing unique things so for
a lot of you listening and watching Andy
K who some of you know but I I'm curious
to see how he introduces himself and
then we'll get into the show Andy krak
I'm the president of V friends I've had
the privilege of working with Gary for
almost a decade now started as an intern
for his book jab jab jab right hook and
now I'm on the second episode of podcast
with friends as a substitute uh twitch
famam because I want to really give you
some incredible access one of Cu I've
never done podcast live before I'm going
to allow for you to ask questions only
about halfway through shows where you
have context so please be listening and
feel free to jump in put put hashtag
question and put your question I'll rely
on my incredibly good-looking producers
here to like figure out what they want
to throw at me ad hoc but let's go back
around the table so these are always
very timely um in the US we just had
Thanksgiving but even if you know you
were not in the US celebrating
Thanksgiving I'm curious for all three
of you and we'll go back around the same
way as we're wrapping up the year 2023
what was the thing that you most learned
about
yourself wow that's such a great
question um what I learned about myself
especially now going through a ton of
therapy is uh really prioritizing me and
putting myself first and my needs my
wants feeling comfortable in that yeah
just like really for so long it's been
about other people I have two young kids
um I recently separated from my ex-wife
so there's just so much change going on
yeah so I've been prioritizing myself
which in the end is going to make me a
better mom a better human a better
friend I I believe in it tremendously I
genuinely believe the best way to be
selfless is to be selfish yes I
genuinely believe that it's why I like
entrepreneurship I'm very aware that
some people may demonize it like that's
bad but like I actually think like if
you can't scratch your itch or if you
can't be happy like it's very clear to
me that unhappy people make others
unhappy and happy people make happy
people happy like it's uncomfortably
clear and it's tough to say out loud
like I'm going to be selfish to be
selfless but I actually have never seen
anyone capable of selflessness unless
they were in an incredible Place well
it's like what are you working for as
well it's like the the the the bigger
goal is what is the end goal of all of
it and I think it's very easy to like
just get caught in the rat race and just
like work work work work do this do that
do that and then you forget the actual
why you doing this and and I think it's
like so pick us up did you what did you
learn this year I think that's the thing
is like the why it's like it's very easy
to just keep working that was your year
this year like you got more into why
yeah good yeah and do you feel like all
of us I'm sure all of us and everybody's
watching everyone's going to listen like
there you know at some level you wake up
somewhere in your adulthood and you
realize why am I still stuck in high
school like why am I still in a place
where other people's validation is the
currency of my thinking
yeah yeah I think I think it's also the
why can change and actually like
allowing yourself to change like the
reason why you're doing it and things
can happen in your personal life that
can affect your work life and then it's
and then completely switches everything
it's like what you were saying going
through therapy going through divorces
breakups and everything like that all of
that can change and realistically we
will do what we love which actually adds
into our real life it is our real life
it's not work and life it's life is all
of it yeah I'm I'm a big fan of what
you're saying like I just I think the
world is obsessed with or and black and
white and I'm just like that there's no
mapping to the way that's not how
it's all
gray yeah cuz it's too circumstantial I
love when people spew like listen I live
on the internet spewing things I'm
passionate about but I don't think I'm
right I think these are perspectives
that I'm observing and I'm
hopeful that for someone in a stream
that moment this topic could bring value
yeah but I think everyone's spending
time trying to convince everybody to see
the world World they way they see it and
it's just like it's just not the way it
is no not at all so for you this was a
Big Y year yeah and did you come to any
interesting conclusions no not really
what about what about no I think I think
it's a forever game what about a running
hypo what was a fun observation that you
got out of it I think for me it was like
especially like taking it very to like
my career it's like there's space for
everybody in I got it so where you're
going is I don't need to compare myself
exactly got it yeah exactly that I love
that you went there like by the way I'm
obsessed with that like you're winning
all the time and that's for damn sure
first of all I love you let's go I love
that first of all we're going to end
this podcast right now thank you for
watching twitch thank you for list but
one's my big thing is someone else's
victories are not my losses like this
scar City mindset thing is fascinating
as if someone else winning in you know
Sports you play a game someone wins
someone lose that's why I love it it's
so absolute but in life like not games
like 7,000 DJs could be winning plus
every DJ's winning is different mhm you
uh we're building an intellectual
property Pokemon and Marvel or in nft
land the web 3 land Bard ape or peguins
or Cool Cats I want them to win I don't
think them winning means that V friends
can't nothing Pokemon Marvel Hello Kitty
gi. Joe Transformers My Little Ponies
and every other like Harry Potter none
of that is stopping me from achieving
what I want well I guess also say the
more they win the more it brings people
to the market that's EXA first of all
that's absolutely right like like you
know who what in your world what really
pisses me off is when someone is a
Pioneer in a genre yeah and then it
leads to more I I'll think about EDM cuz
I'm old I'm 48 so watching that whole
scene happened was very clear I watched
it similar to hip-hop but I was a kid
when like EDM was like okay I like
really understood what was happening oh
this is a genre oh oh this is what aichi
means to this like this is cool that's
like run the MC like I understood
watching people pioneer something win
other people follow at scale and then
those people are mad at the people that
created the thing because they think
like that that always you should be
thanking them not envious of them if you
weren't good enough which is what it is
that's all it is people or not willing
to work hard enough that's right which
is part of good like work you know when
hustle became like a word I couldn't say
anymore slang turned it into burnout I
was like cool I won't use that work
ethic yeah like I promise you I know all
three of you in different ways nobody's
at this table without work ethic it just
doesn't work that way nobody just hopes
their way no one's cutting Corners it it
doesn't happen like I think people work
hard and don't achieve things
materialistically but I have met very
few people who don't have a sense of
pride of their work ethic one of my
favorite people on paper is someone who
didn't have entrepreneurial Spirit
didn't have an X Factor by the way
didn't even want to have an x- Factor
just takes incredible I have many people
in my circles whose number one pride is
that they've worked their face off like
a 9 to5 but they put their kids through
school yeah in a world where their
parents didn't and they're good MH
they're like and now I'm just going to
bowl and drink [__] beer I'll I'll
see you on the flip side well it circles
back around to the why well that's it
well this is what gets me into like
desperately trying to redefine success
like one of my pet projects to the day I
die is to change the conversation around
success success cannot be money and
stuff it's why so many people AR happy
mhm success needs to be understanding
yourself and finding that place of Peace
cuz you're just in your process whatever
that is how do you get there though how
did you get there I got there by luck
and and I don't throw around lucky I I
hate that word I hate it cuz people
weaponize it against people that work
hard I worked hard but you have to
understand I will say luck here because
at 6 years old I gravitated towards
90-year-old people at the park in
Queens I think I believe in old souls I
believe in some people just born with
wisdom I cannot tell you why at 7 8
years old [__] seems simple for me I
Can't Tell You Why at 10 years old I
decided to not be good at school anymore
cuz I realized it didn't matter I can't
tell you why I moonwalked through high
school cuz I never and I mean ever have
felt peer pressure right or a need to
fit in yeah I had really really good DNA
and I had a worldclass mother who found
super balance between building
self-confidence but not creating
entitlement or softness so like you know
it's why I kind of don't give a [__]
about me yeah like one of the reasons I
just walk around and like I'm aware that
people think I'm cool and I understand
how many followers I have I understand
what's happening to me I don't associate
with it at all I'm obsessed with what
people that actually really have known
me for a long time and people that are
getting I'm UPS I like care way more
what you two now think of me in an hour
than I did an hour ago MH I'm obsessive
about people that really know me what
they think because my validation comes
from people viewing me as a nice person
yeah mhm but as far as like the things
that most people know me for that's just
not where my validation sits yeah and I
think that just that's C there's a lot
of circumstances went into it in the
first 20 years and then somewhere around
4 35 I'm like wait a minute yeah like it
started becoming clear to me I'm like
I'm telling everybody what to do in
business no one's doing it wait a minute
they're scared to do it why wait a
minute why are they scared wait a minute
yeah grown-ups still think it's high
school for someone who didn't think high
school was high school that's what got
me down the journey if you look at my
content it evolved yeah yeah it started
with like tactical like do this on
Twitter and it will work and then I was
like why is no one doing it and then it
started getting into this which is why
I'm so happy that human beings now can
say out loud therapy where 40 years ago
you could it yeah so true you're going
to a psychiatrist you're crazy now it's
like we're just 20 years away from
people going to therapy the way we go to
school school yeah and that's good yeah
it will be good going back on the
success thing how do you cope with that
from being extremely successful in your
career to then retiring and being like
what my favorite subject of athletes
really yeah because I have a sports
agency yeah and and I grew up obsessive
about sports MH and I think you're
asking an incredible question I'm so
happy and I grew up my whole life
wishing I was an athlete but being
thrilled that I settled into being an
entrepreneur cuz I got a little taste of
it but then as I got older I'm like
[__] these people they found
their especially the one you you know
this some people are athletes that
really love their sport others are
completely indifferent it's their way to
financial success or to get out that was
a brain [__] yeah but for the ones that
love it yeah the idea of being in your
30s yeah if everything goes remarkable
in your and now with modern medicine and
training maybe you're 40 if you're one
of the greats of all time in whatever
sport but like most likely late 20s
early 30s by the way if you're in the 1%
yeah you know like and then you're such
a young woman right now I just turned 38
I played a long career but you're a
[__] child yeah like real talk I know
you live the real life you got a lot
going on you got kids but Real Talk 38
is like especially got like the way lot
more to like honestly you're probably
going to live for a minimum of 62 more
years well I hope so so but just think
about but think about that for a second
that's [__] insane you've lived like
a real [__] full like life mhm and
yet you're a third in so scary to think
that way and epic yeah it's pretty cool
you have like another PR let's say for
instance you stop work you retire at 60
5 70 you've got a whole new life to do
what the I mean for me I loved like
soccer was not who I was it's what I did
yeah but at some point your body takes
such a toll and it affects your mental
health so much like it just started to
get hard to get out of bed you know like
people don't realize how how much like
especially women's sports I have no
pension I walked away years I have no I
don't have four 1ks I don't like I have
by the way by the way men's sports are
not so [__] great either like but at
least they make millions of dollars
where they but you know what's funny if
you're at the top right yeah like like
real talk like the NFL yeah America's
most popular sport two and a half year
average not long most guys are out of
money after five years I like because by
the way unless you go in the first R if
so the way football works is your real
money comes in your second contract
which is the fourth or fifth year of
your career almost everybody's out after
two and a half and if you don't go in
the first or second round which don't
forget if you're out a league in 2 and a
half years as a first or second round
pick you're a massive bust and you have
to deal with that yeah mentally yeah
financially you got a little more money
if you're a third or fourth or fifth
round pick you're making hundreds of
thousands of dollars not millions and by
the way you have to pay taxes mhm you're
normally a cliche kid and bought some
dumb [__] like a house and a car and a
chain and so like most people that go
play in the NFL when they're 26 are
finished with it and have to get jobs
yeah and what people also don't
understand is like and you know you've
been in sports for so long it's you're
you're really a machine you're trained
to be I was trained to be a machine and
you Lo like you lose sight of reality a
lot of times because that is what your
life is that is who you are you're
competit like I couldn't stand for
someone to beat me in ping pong I
couldn't stand if someone walked
upstairs faster than I love you so much
I'm on a mission to make competitiveness
understood again I think
it's look look as you know it sounds
like we're similar everything everything
is good in Balance yes I don't think
it's nice that I like am willing to like
punch a kid that's not that's not that's
not accepted in society I get it but I'd
be lying if I didn't tell you my
chemicals if like my son is getting
really good at basketball and I'm like
oh crap I need to beat him as many times
as possible right now cuz unlike AJ my
brother who was 11 years younger than me
I I was you know he was I think 17 the
first time he beat me I was 28 like I
was still like athletic like I was still
28 I'm 48 and my son is actually a
modern basketball kid which means he can
dribble his they're all step curried out
he's all step back AJ played more like
the generation I came up with there was
no massive step back to creates
separation and you can hit a three from
half court so you're saying your son is
better than you my son is so
uncomfortably better than me now now now
luckily right now I'm also a grown ass
man he's a child so I can still be up 11
nothing but I already envisioned this
weekend after playing a little bit I'm
like oh I'm going to have to like really
get physical on him in two or three
years like I don't need him winning
before he's 15 like I can't lose to a
12-year-old but I'm going to have to
body him up and like kind of weirdly
hurt him you have to true but it's very
different when we were raised we did
everything we played every
now everything specialized well that's
cuz all these parents are [__] out of
their mind and think their kids are
going to be Pros fair I mean these
parents are so [__] delusional I was
at this Central Park baseball game a
couple years ago where like these two
dads were just getting out of I finally
just likez I can get loud I'm like
friends nobody at this park is playing
Major League
Baseball like this is all fun in games
but do you understand what's going on in
Central and South America right now like
every kid is kid's age three times the
size and throwing 90 M an hour there's
no soft kid in Manhattan going to the
league Harrison Bader is the anomaly not
the preview all right Andy yes sir what
did you learn about yourself this year
um I would say instead of the the why
the how you talk a lot about focusing on
your strengths and puning your
weaknesses and I would say that's
something I learned this year how to
scale everything we're doing at vriends
and in my personal life and not giving a
[__] about things that I suck at and
making sure that I have people give us
an example of something you suck at that
you came to grips with this year cuz
these vulnerabilities and like these
real talks like I'm watching the chat as
well like what I what I think is
happening I had a hunch when I started
this podcast that one on Three like when
I do dinner there's a reason like all of
my friends over the last decade
professionally have fallen in love with
the idea of one conversation with 5 10
15 not 15 5 10 you've been in a lot of
them 5 10 people at a dinner table it's
the [__] best and it goes like real
and already in a quarter way into
episode two I can feel it like they're
different conversations that if I had
you individually so just because there's
so much trust between you and I I have
no idea where you're about to go but I'm
genuinely curious just to empower people
listening like go real real with me what
what this year were you like I'm just
not good at
this or or I'm not as good as I wish to
be wor not good at it's feeling like
because I'm in the role that I'm in I
feel like I need to do it and
understanding and being self aware
they're like actually this person's
better than me at that and they're going
to do a great job at it and I can let
them run with
it got it so like having this major
leadership role which you earned from
intern to this and it's high-profile
especially in our and learning the role
like it doesn't I don't have to be the
one doing it as long as I'm
understanding it Boyd did you Mike
Boyd's in the background who's obviously
done music with me forever Tyler Walsh
has now been with us for what three
years four years actually just two two
well this is actually cool because I
think this is the compliment and flowers
I'm giving him when Walsh joined a team
and you've been like the central figure
you my music plug it's your identity we
have a playlist together like you're
very well known we've had a good run
I've been a little head down these last
couple years but we had this coming off
this crazy run in music and Hip-Hop our
genre that we love so
much what did you learn that Walsh was
better at than you and did you struggle
with that or did you like were you ready
for it because you were stretched or did
it hurt a little bit because your whole
identity in this thing was this and
you're like [__] this kid's got cuz you
were also going through a part in your
life when you got married you had a kid
and like you know I assume when you're
let's call what it is you two are a
andrs like there's some advantages to
having 15 hours a day to listening to
music and finding someone that a Walsh
coming up the game can do that maybe
that you used to like I'm curious for
you yeah um yeah so Tyler Walsh he's
watching he's the best and when he
joined the team it was great to see him
go above and beyond without me asking
yeah self that helped me realize I could
let him handle it yeah even on the way
here we were talking while I was driving
and I told him hey we could talk about
this in a minute I need you to do
something but we'll do it together
potentially if you need help he already
had it done by the time we hung up a lot
of times he'll send me a video and he'll
be like look I really think we need to
do this these are the reasons it could
work like I didn't even ask him to make
the video I show up to work he's like I
was reworking rethinking everything
we've been doing and like without his
help you know a lot of that would not
about I think about that a lot I also
think about like you too and your
disrespect like the things that like I
think it's such a real thing Andy like
you know this go ahead please I see you
want to say something well it's another
thing like it's really rewarding to
watch the people that you're managing or
the people around you get credit for the
work and not feeling like I need to get
credit like you giving dabs to Ezra for
something I'm like that's so cool I'm so
pumped that he got to get that
validation from you and I don't and I
think if that's happening I'm in a good
place and the team's rocking and rolling
that's
right maybe I should join what what what
did I Lear about myself this year I
think I've doubled down on like my
kryptonite back to being lucky and I'm
comfortable making a Superman analogy
which is actually a weakness my Superman
of it all is a weakness like I was
raised as the first I was the oldest
child in the Immigrant family that was
born in the old country that had a
younger sister from day one my mom is
like you take care of her plus both my
parents lost a parent very young my mom
lost her mom at five my dad lost his dad
at 16 most of my childhood I feared one
of my parents dying like it was a
constant play track in my mind so like I
don't know my dad worked every minute
cuz we were an immigrant family so I
don't know like at five like I don't
know by seven for sure I'm like I'm the
M I'm the guy I'm the leader mhm and
like but does that take away the
childhood as well of course it does it's
a real
like plenty of like the way I think
about my life and when I go into like
therapy mode whether in therapy or like
cuz I'm always in therapy mode cuz I'm
always thinking like yeah there's a lot
so much of what made me me and like made
me pop both in real life and then you
know since I last 15 years in public
life is so much about that but it's also
my kryptonite yeah like like my lack of
cander Gary Vee is a cander beast that's
what people fell in love with me for
getting to the punchline but in real
life if I loved you it was really hard
as a business leader especially and in
my personal life you know like you know
you I really resonate with like putting
oneself first like I enjoy making people
happy I enjoy I enjoy being I get it you
think it's your superpower yeah like I
think my superpower is taking care of
everything and making everyone feel safe
the problem is we're human beings and so
like when it was too much for me it
would come out as passive aggressive
razes like something you know like and
Andy so like like the way I would manage
boy you know less because of the way our
but definitely Andy who was on my
content team said like my go-to if I was
frustrated was not to speak canderous
and just like cut to the Chase and move
on it was like little slights in jokey
form because I didn't want it to be too
much poison but like you walk away
you're like yo what was that joke
it was true you know for sure and like
you rely on the fact that you have a
real relationship and I can get away
with it because I'm providing a lot of
value but over time I realized that's
not right and it was my
vulnerability and so I would say the
thing I learned this year was probably
the continuation of something that's
been the theme for the last 5 years
which is if I can ever figure out how to
get great at what I now call kind cander
mhm which I would say I'm at a four to
five four let's call 4.5 out of 10 yeah
but coming from 2017 Gary being at a one
that 1 to 4.5 has been [__] massive
mhm how did you get how did you get
there though what's the process yeah
realizing people that used to work here
don't like me and I was like that's
impossible yeah like how is that oh
right when I look at please please you
gave a advice I think it might have been
it was to some emerging musicians one
time and I I always tell this advice now
too uh you had said they were about to
pop like really blow up and you're like
what I would say is you guys should have
a day once a month every month every
quarter where you go to the diner and
you know that when you go to the diner
you're going to lay out how you're
feeling and everything that's pent up
and it's going to give you that freedom
and space to be canderous and so many
times I use that yeah so many times I
use that example like a cliche one that
I did with my roommate after hearing
that my roommate like wasn't cleaning up
the kitchen and stuff and it just gets
annoying I I asked like one so the
chat's about
everybody had some roommate that was dir
I was a dirty roommate in college so I'm
like let's talk about your hat I love
that brand like you asked once or twice
and then he's not doing anymore and I'm
like I'm going to stop asking but then
the next time like resentment resent you
want to go play basketball and I'll just
blow up like no [__] you blah and he's
like whoa what are you talking about but
then knowing I'm like okay that oh it's
Friday it's Friday the last Friday of
the month I'm going to tell Chris what's
up and they just created like this safe
space that I as a my parents are both
therapists so I grew up with that every
night at the dinner table and my brother
would be like can you not make us tell
about talk about our feelings can you
like hit us like every other every other
like adult every other parent but it's
like it kind of we were I was so lucky
growing up as a kid cuz it was like
every night was like how you feeling
like what's going on like yeah what have
we done what somebody else done and it's
it's an amazing tool to have I me it's
everything on the flip side I think
about purple a lot so America's
political system is obviously red and
blue MH and I'm just like man we need to
start talking about purple because the
flip side of you know this especially
growing up with those two kind of
parents and I'm sure you know maybe you
your family got fortunate because they
found enough purple but I'm sure they
had contemporaries where all that thing
went too far the other way you know back
to competition I am petrified of eighth
place trophies I I don't even know that
world and I would tell you I understand
why it happened because we would have
compassion for children of course who
would lose and
cry but the incredible amount of
indifference we have created for a
generation has led to a lot of
depression when you don't
care when you think when you're when
you're 24 and you're like it think about
what is the scary thing to hear when you
as a parent when you talk to your
24-year-old and they say it just does
nothing matters it doesn't matter yeah
you know you're in trouble you know
you're having a combo of like scary [__]
you know substance
abuse having real conversations around
suicide and things that scary [__] the
great fear of any parent I just want to
remind people it doesn't matter is
something that was instilled in kids
heads MH and when you tell people that
when they're six and they play and they
are naturally built to be competitive or
care I know I can speak for us to
already in two seconds when people when
I was seven cuz they didn't say this
back in 1982 but if somebody even and
some of my family did if they even
inkling when I lost a monopoly or
pingpong or pool or backyard football if
they even tried to broach the concept of
because I cried every time I lost for
the first seven years of competition so
from 7 to 14 I cried when did that stop
sure it's 14 somewhere around 14 15 I
started fighting yeah I me I fought a
lot as a kid and I because
losing was devastating the thought that
somebody would say to me it doesn't
matter do not tell a child who is wired
to care AKA competitive that it doesn't
matter MH because you are confusing the
[__] out of that poor little thing mhm
of course the only thing if the four if
one of the if you just said hold on you
us four need to race to the door right
now it's the only thing that matters
it's the reverse there is nothing else
yeah I think we've really created a
culture of indifference mhm and I think
it's a problem yeah cuz indifference is
the scary one like it's wonderful if
you're not competitive that's beautiful
it's wonderful if you don't like enjoy
Uno or like great but to take that away
from the other half I think has caused a
lot of weirdness that people don't see
yet what do you uh Chase or value more
the excitement of Victory or just never
wanting to taste defeat like n say a
quote neither it's cool to love to win
but it's better to hate to lose get
honestly neither the genu genuine excuse
me the genuine curiosity of where I
stand it's why I love entrepreneurship
it and and it's the the truth because
when I think back of even winning gold
medals or World Championships the second
I do it I'm like great what's next 100%
what's next that's the kill look at me
as a sports fan I love the Jets and the
Knicks but I equally grew up a Rangers
and Yankees fan equally my high school
friends always like talk about this like
I was a most of my high school friends
think I was a bigger Rangers Fan than a
Jets fan in high school but the Rangers
won the cup in '94 and that was it mhm
that Curiosity was I was curious what it
would feel like to win a Stanley Cup and
then I did and then it was just not as
interesting but on a deeper level to
that how do you when you achieve things
cuz I'm I I can relate to that massively
whereas like you you set goals you
achieve them and then it's like what's
next but there comes a point when there
isn't a
next I just think there's this inner
like competition that fuels me so it's
not so much about what what you get from
doing it it's the process and journey
while you're in it I [__] with I [__]
with it like every day like and I and
it's funny cuz we're going to keep
bringing up therapy because I'm in it a
lot right now like I was so the amount
of self talk I had as an athlete I
[__] knew I was great and like I was
so kind to myself and I didn't cut
Corners all of my confidence came in my
preparation but like it switches off
when I'm in the real world in real life
oh interesting it's so weird did you
have as you so weird yeah the I don't
think it's weird I think it's different
Arenas yeah who we are as a professional
is different than who we are in a
relationship different who we are with
friend we have a lot of different
versions of ourselves like I was not
scared to knock on doors and sell stuff
at 6 but at 14 like asking a girl out
was still like uh I know like like we
have just slightly you know like you
just you're just different in different
places certain places you have fear some
people jump out of airplanes I'm like
[__] that [__] but but then here like
would never like try to sell something
they're like I can't do that or public
speak like when when that when I realize
how many people are completely Fear
public speaking like I'm like that's my
bed that's my home that's the coziest
place I know that's Cozier to me than
anything I do we're like the same when I
when I went to college I took acting
class poetry class and public speaking
love for electives love because I was
like oh do this [__] in my sleep yeah
I'm not doing stuff where I have to like
actually
work like I'm good I get it send me in
front of a like a camera or in front of
a group and I'll just be M I'm different
when I'm cooking in the kitchen at work
all like like just just different
different versions all right friends
we're going to open a pack of be friends
so these are my Pokemon meets Marvel
Sesame Street kind of world here's the
game everyone it's good you can open
everybody opens and then I want you look
at four all four characters and tell me
which character speaks to you and
why okay I've got
mine
H DJ will you go
first which be friend of your pack which
vs did you pull legit llama boisterous
Beaver shrewd sheep and the sincere
skunk okay and which one speaks to you
the most uh legit llama why I think for
me it's like I know exactly what I'm
doing for myself and it's like it's not
about anybody else now it used to be
about everybody else and kind of caring
about what every what was what was the
Tipping
Point
um some
like fat personal family stuff that
happened and it was just like the the
focus just completely changed mhm and it
was like okay now
is nothing else no one else matters
right it's just I'm just doing what I
want to do because I want to do it and
if I if it does well it does well if it
doesn't I'm enjoying the like process
it's everything yeah love it I'm going
to go with the Fearless fairy right now
go let's [__] go and and I say this
because I'm I'm like in this Pursuit and
I said this very I said this at Von a
little bit ago too it's like I'm tired
of of worrying about being understood
yeah I feel like as public yeah as
public figures so quickly like
narratives are constantly ran and
questioned about your happiness your
health who you are and it's really
conflicting and jading and it pushes you
off your process a lot because it's like
you could read 500 comments that people
say about you're you're the goat you're
the goat you're the goat and then one
and then it just like is so crippling
and I can I tell you something on that
please this is real talk and honestly
one of the reasons I'm saying this is
it's very obvious that the whole Andy
Warhol 15 minutes of fame thing like the
whole I I heard this very early in
Twitter 2006 seven I don't remember when
I first heard it but the whole it's not
15 minutes of fame anymore it's everyone
is going to be famous to 15 people is
[__] real yeah like every child
that's listening to this thinks about
their personal brand mhm that's crazy
it's crazy now now now I want to remind
parents that are like this is [__] up
[__] social that's how we all lived
anyway it was just that your personal
brand was in the four walls of your high
school it's called reputation but it's
obviously different Dynamics I see it as
amazing because some of us grew up in
towns where nobody could understand us
but we could find our homies now on
Twitch or Tik Tok like I like it I'm
aware of the reverse but I will say
something to you that I want you to hear
that I'm very passionate about and this
is for everybody who's listening
especially parents to say something to
their kid we we talked about this
earlier about selflessness and
selfish a human
being that took time in their life to
either find you or or consume one of
your pieces of content and their
reaction was to take time to try to hurt
you is in a very bad place we have to as
a society this is just good for everyone
this has to become the way the world
looks at it we have to stop feeling bad
for ourselves don't become delusional
and an [__] and out of touch every
negative comment I get and I get plenty
even though I'm a pretty positive guy
cuz I'm just at scale mhm I like kind of
look at it like hey am I high am my own
Supply like this is like I don't want
like I don't want to become a character
to myself I'm reading them all cuz I
think it's valuable to check myself yes
but I do not internalize it I deeply
deploy compassion and sympathy for
someone who's L I have never in my life
decided to go to somebody's account and
leave well think about what I'm saying
we've not broken this down you are
laying in bed you're walking down the
street you're on a plane and you were in
such a bad place that you want to go see
someone else's light and you need to
make yourself feel better misery loves
company sayings exist for a reason you
need to close the gap on your wound
you're only reconciling just like people
go to drugs and alcohol and food and
other things to deal the way you deal
with your unhappiness is you want to
hurt someone else that's bad have you
ever reached out to them all the time I
used to do it you want to do you know
from 2007 to 11 I reached out to all of
them really every single person for five
years that left me something negative I
interacted with yeah I respect that it's
why [__] was going so good for me for a
while like everybody who everybody who
was like initially like [__] this dude
[__] like they were like wait a minute
and like so now I had like you know in
essence they became the people that most
liked me of course yeah yeah now it's
just at so much scale I don't I can't
get there but I really hope that
everybody not just us four get to that
place because it's 100% true I was
trying to think of a funny tweet where
you used to reply a little bit I just
book barked this and I'm going to come
back to it in 2025 or whatever the case
was it was a funny rebuttal Andy yours
what did you pull I pulled hyp horse
unwavering urchin skilled skeleton and
bullish bull I'm going with bullish bull
I'm just bullish on life and the opport
opportunities at hand and I'm feeling
bullish you're in you're in a good place
yeah I'm in a great place I'm in America
I'm in Hudson yards I just try to
maintain perspective and I just think
every day is an amazing opportunity no
matter where you are but especially
where I am I love that I'm going with
common sense
cow I believe that as the world becomes
more complex there's amazing things
we're more thoughtful no humans like us
four 30 years ago talk like this unless
you were in a family that like this was
unheard of talk unheard of Love on the
flip side what is it uh ignores Bliss
yeahh like one of the things that is
incredibly waning in our society is
common sense people are overthinking
everything so much that you've
overthought it so much that you don't
even know how to cross the [__]
Street
M and so I'm obsessed with common sense
I the reason I made Common Sense cow was
I knew I know that cows are easy to you
know sea urchins are a little bit
weirder than cows like I gave a lot of
thought to like who was what and who
they were going to be and like Fearless
Ferry for a reason like I like you know
like like but Common Sense cow is like
super important to me because I'm going
to develop these stories for the rest of
my life I first thought it was more
Disney now I realized it's more Jim
Henson Sesame Street become incredibly
impressed with Jim Henson's life I
didn't realiz the magnitude of his
intent behind Fraggle Rock you know what
Fraggle Rock is you know that there's a
big show in the 80s on HBO when HBO was
like new and cable and it was huge
especially for twitch who knows what
fragle rock is give me some love I'm
sure it's been rebooted on the streaming
service
anyway there was a creative brief that
he gave to his writers to create a show
called Fraggle Rock usually these things
are like a [__] packet or at least a
mission statement
his entire thing when he cuz I met we
met the woman who did it was literally
the whole brief stop War wow create a
kids program that will stop
War yeah I honestly like it was a cool
meeting the the woman who worked for Jim
Henson and she's in her 70s a British
woman she took the call by way of an
introduction she didn't know anything
about Gary she had no idea what she was
getting it was very clear within the
first two seconds that she was that she
was there to be nice to someone else and
probably
maybe maybe did a quick Google search
and like [__] this
guy and then she got the Gary ve keynote
of what he created vs for and then she
was like excited she's like Not only was
she excited this woman probably paid me
one of the great comp especially I was
always like Jim Henson's Rad but like
now that I've been on this journey I'm
like whoa Jim Henson's like Super Rad
she she paid me an insane compliment
she's like she's like she even I think
the reason we're both saying it this way
I think she was even like so British and
straight forward she was like mate let
just to keep it real with you I came
into this just just check the like she
was that awesome she's like but honestly
I've never felt like this cuz I really
went I felt like I needed to like show
her that this was real [__] for me not
like I want to sell some [__] cards
and uh she paid me a really nice
compliment and said that the way she was
feeling reminded her of the way she felt
as a young
around why did you stop V friends
because Gary ve has been very effective
yeah like the
guilt and gratitude yeah that I have of
the luck notice the word I used one of
my least favorite words in the world I
believe luck is weaponized by unhappy
people to weaponize against people that
are trying hard I don't like it that
being said I used it because I'm in
guilt and gratitude of who I am you want
to talk like the I loved the way you
talked about being like ready for your
sport that's how I feel about life like
I genuinely think I can beat everybody
on Earth in life MH it's very
unsettling like it's
incredibly powerful it makes me
unwaveringly happy like nothing scares
me outside of the health of the people I
love
nothing especially when you know you're
willing to live in the dirt like all
this is
garbage do you know my favorite Rocky is
when he lost everything and had to go
back yeah yeah dude I'm a weird like one
like nobody gave a [__] about phoen like
I
love the process yeah nothing I went
from not even be able to go to a Knicks
game to finally being able to buy a
ticket and sit way up there and now I
can sit Courtside and if tomorrow
something happened and I went back to
having to be only able to buy a $100 or
$300 ticket and sit way up okay and what
and what's going to happen and you're
going to make fun of me that I used to
what does like I'm just I can't this
goes back to the comments here's the key
I don't believe the
accolades yeah mhm if you don't believe
the accolades you don't believe the hate
mm if really interesting that cuz like
when it comes to Awards right there's
Awards in sports there's Awards in music
there's Awards in business and
everything you've probably won awards
for what you've done probably let's talk
about being a businessman yeah if you
talk to my Financial people they despise
my relationship with money they're like
you're a [__] businessman I'm like I
don't give a [__] yeah MH I'm one of the
lucky few maybe some people on Twitch
will know where I'm going with this if
you were born into not much yeah and you
get to being about seven and your first
seven years is filled with nothing but
joy and happiness and you didn't have
[__] which is my life my mother was so
gangster in like pure over the top
optimism Joy love she gave me everything
of sunshine rainbows and hearts MH and
we didn't have [__] so who the [__] do
you think I am as a 48-year old man I'm
a 48-year old man who fully understands
there is no correlation of money and
stuff and happiness and yet most of the
world lives their whole life trying to
buy a car or a chain or a building or a
plane or because they believe that once
they get that then I'll show all
everyone's running on resentment I'm
running on gratitude it's also really
easy though to say that from like we're
all in a privilege point right it's very
easy this why I keep referencing my high
school like my high school friends know
that I was making $40,000 a year at 26
living in a shitty Springfield New
Jersey apartment and knew I was the
happiest person in the bunch even though
a lot of them were starting to make
money in Wall Street and so like for me
yes I am aware that 99% of people that
are listening right right now either
don't believe me or don't know or will
take me on my word but I also know that
there's hundreds of people that know
it's true I was more happy at 30 I just
had less responsibilities Diddy and
Biggie had it right yeah More Money More
Problems is real so it really is you
know like when I was in my pure process
building a company for my parents I felt
at the top of my game I was sacrificing
my 20s to build a company for my dad and
mom what's more noble like I was [__]
perfect
mhm you know now you get like all the
noise and as much as I've got it like
I'm still a human like sure I got my
Force filled up but like you know it's
like you know something can slip through
once every two three years for four
minutes you know so anyway yeah I'm just
incred anyway where was I going oh be
friends I've done some real damage yeah
damage is a slang term of good I have
you know this you ran my social with me
you know this that's like I have
unlimited DMS that are going to come
into my DM tonight yeah of people
talking about being suicidal alcoholics
hitting the do you know what it feels
like to be on the receiving end of I
just listen to a podcast and I don't
know what the [__] you do or who what
what but you said two things and I just
want to be vulnerable with you and I
feel safe in this DM I've been hitting
my spouse and I will never hit her again
because of you yeah do you know what
that feels like it's deep it's deep as
[__] when I take selfies it's not
because I'm a world class athlete or
because I'm a [__] shockingly
handsome or because I make people laugh
or give them incredible escapism through
sport or music or it's because I'm
talking about things that like they're
actually doing either to like sell
things like garage sales and get their
family out of debt or completely sh it's
what you're pay it's why I admire your
parents in you know one gene of non-
Entrepreneurship and I'm your parents
yeah yeah I'm a guidance counselor I'm a
head coach I'm a teacher I'm a therapist
and so you know vriends is yeah I've
reached a lot of people but there's a
billion and I'm not the person that's
going to reach them all MH and by the
way as every day goes by I become less
easy to be relevant to course My Success
keeps building yeah you know like you
know like if you want to reach kids like
I don't know a 50-year-old white dude
who's got a lot of money even though my
story is real like it gets harder and
harder but guess what a cute little bull
or some of my favorite characters
accountable ant let's talk about
accountable ant I believe the number one
reason people are [__] up is because
they're not accountable you want to get
real happy real fast literally look
yourself in the mirror and say 100% of
everything that is not working for me is
my fault that's true and don't beat
yourself up and say I'm a piece of [__]
I'm a loser no no the second you go
there you realize you can then also fix
it mm but if you're blaming Biden or
Trump or countries or China or the
league or the media or social media or
Tik Tok or Elon or Twitter or twitch or
or Fox News or CNN or like if you're
just well then you're saying I'm not in
control
[__] 100 I think even for me like in in
my kind of Realm like social media is
massive as we all know it's massive for
all of us but like the likes of Tik Tok
for me like Tik Tok just doesn't do it
for me it's just not for me and there's
people that are in my career or in my
industry that are way bigger than me
because they do Tik Tok and it's like
I'm for me it's like accepting the fact
that I would never I I cannot stand it
so why do it it makes me so unhappy so
why do it I know I'm not going to be as
successful as them but so what brother
it's like I can't be bothered I could
probably own the Jets like business goal
right now if I was willing to do things
that I didn't like if I didn't if I was
willing to do things I don't like it'd
be a rap yeah I would have started a
crazy hedge fund or a private like like
I'm like I would have just been an
investor after I invested in Facebook
Twitter and Tumblr like I was in it yeah
you wouldn't have the admiration that
you have from others though that's for
damn sure yeah and not that like that's
like you know what's funny it's not like
IND it's like honestly I ju like I've
like back to like going through the
process like I love my parents so much
that like no question making them proud
is like super big for me but I got lucky
because the thing that my mom put on a
pedestal who predominantly parented me
obviously like like my dad is a big
factor in my life he just like to his
credit he worked to build our life then
at 14 I worked with him every day and so
I got very lucky I got them both more so
than my siblings
did my mom's pedestal was not money yeah
was not ad not fame it was be nice to
people yeah that's why positive
reinforcement as parents is such an
important thing if you tell the reason
so many people work for people is cuz
their parents told them grades were
important and so they just became
conformists get an a AK be a good
manager compan takes to do that yeah
play the system which is a fake system
just like I don't know like it's such an
interesting time in the world anyway I
do please sorry I do think it's but I do
think it's something to know which I
find I admire so much about you to be so
cuz you are such a giver you are you're
very it matters to you how people see
you and feel your presence but you don't
lose yourself in the process and I feel
like I that's a that's a learning
because for so long being in the
spotlight doing this Social Media stuff
do I was giving I was giving I was
giving I was so empty inside I was a
shell of a human so at what point yeah
it's the hardest balance to find it's
complete it's a very [__] up thing
I I it I I always wondered like will
somebody invent a machine that could
actually like tap into you like a lie
detector test and actually show everyone
everything like I dream of this machine
because if that happened right now and I
plugged in you would [__] faint how
much good I want for you and want to
provide for you the problem is then
there would be a comma after all of that
mhm and that comma would be followed
with you being like what the [__] just
happened because it would show you how
much I do not give a [__] about what you
think yeah that which is a superpower
that is like pulling so and that's why
it's like such a fun life it's why
everyone I meet I'm just like going to
give and give and give and if you don't
reciprocate I don't feel bad yeah I
didn't get the re the reason everyone's
like when I say nice so I've been
thinking about building a fashion brand
called first nice guys finish first
right great call me yeah so people are
constantly constantly saying to me
you're so [__] up with this G you
don't it's all delusional I like I'm
like you just don't understand what I'm
saying which is like if you're truly
nice I believe most people posture
manipulation into being that they're
nice most people that like I've run
across that are trying to be nice are
trying to be nice to me to set up the
ask 100% I remember when it first
started happening Gary I'll do you a
huge favor I see her coming to Dallas
I'll give you a ride from the airport
right so like instead of like laying in
the back of a car that I paid 50 bucks
for so I can like actually rest after a
long flight and like maybe call my kids
you want me to go into your car so you
can pitch me your business and like like
and you're packaging it that's that was
always like the funny extreme example
but I think a lot of people that feel
like they get walked all over for being
nice need to look in the mirror and
realize they're actually setting up a
manipulation yeah or they're deeply
insecure and their validation comes for
like being walked onh there is no other
version yeah cuz pure niess is
undefeated when you're nice you give
without expectation yes which means you
can't be hurt yeah the reason I'm never
hurt is I've zero m
expectation to my actions towards them
should not be reciprocated in any way
I'm not doing it for any other reason
then it feels good I love that I'm aware
that it may lead to some like I
understand life I just wish more people
like went all in all right wrapping
up obviously I mean we this like zoomed
by and I'm sure there was a couple
things maybe on your mind that you want
to talk about or tell people about I
want that for you I'm what I'm setting
up now is permission to tell the
millions of people over the next half
decade that listen to this anything
you'd like them to know or follow or or
something you want to talk about so
before we get out of here part I feel
like we yeah I feel like we hit it but
it's so I'm really happy you do this
it's really special it's really amazing
just to have a really vulnerable
conversation and I love that people are
so genuine and open to it and I'm happy
I got to do this with you guys today
likewise yeah the same for me
um yeah it's just nice to speak to
people that you don't know and that you
can relate on the same level as them and
kind of have the same conversation is
you don't often get it nowadays as well
it's hard to like dig on a bit of a
deeper level and it's even harder to
like it was funny 20 years ago it was
easier for me to find them now people
are posturing of it but it's not fashion
it's fashionable it's fashionable to
have a therapist it's fashionable to do
what correct which is great but but the
problem is people are using it as makeup
to disguise their real intent exactly
that's right yeah yeah
Andy um I'm grateful that I got to be
maybe the
best uh substitute
guest subtitute uh and I hope to see
Ashlin and uh the crew back at Von in
2024 can't wait yeah la this time August
uh 8th to the 11th La V.C Co check it
out my parting is first to the twitch
family thank you for being here I [__]
up I promised you some questions I'm
going to let Dustin and team grab three
or four and I'm going to film answers
and use it for social media content
which is 10 times better cuz you're
going to get full exposure for that so
we'll make that good number two twitch
crew uh I'm going over to Fanatics live
right now um so I know a lot of you I
saw in the chat came over to watch this
I'm going back over there I'm about to
give away a ton of free be friends
Collectibles so download the app go over
there I'm going to assume that most of
you know how to get there if not please
leave some comments to the rest of the
twitch family and I I'll leave everybody
with this please hit me up on Twitter
Gary V e e which with the quote or the
statement or the topic that most hit you
from this episode cuz I always love to
hear like what people attached to I can
also share it with my friends here thank
you all for being on podcast with
friends and we will see you next time
can't wait
[Music]
peace